Hey Thoughty2 here.
A lot of things that you would naturally assume
are against the law, aren't in many parts
of the world.
There are some really strange, and often disturbing
things that you can legally get away with.
First up is cannibalism.
Yes you heard that right, in most countries
around the world, including the United States
and most of Europe, there are no outright
laws against the consumption of human flesh.
In most cases cannibals are charged with murder.
However if someone willingly gives you permission
to hack off a piece of their flesh and eat
it, you're strangely not doing anything illegal.
Have you ever wanted to own a tiger?
Well you're in luck, it's illegal to own a
tiger in the UK under the Dangerous Wild Animals
Act.
But in Canada and several US states it's completely
fine in the eyes of the law to go online and
buy a tiger then bring it home, which is easier
than you may think.
In case you were wondering a baby bengal tiger
will cost you around $1,000.
In 14 US states it's legal to own a tiger,
however you are required to register for a
permit to own large cats.
However in 9 states there are no laws against
it whatsoever, you can just go ahead and buy
one, despite the significant risks they can
pose to the public.
In fact there are currently 12,000 privately
owned pet tigers in America, and that excludes
the ones kept in zoos.
Next up is radar detectors.
These nifty little boxes sit on your car's
dashboard and will alert you if your speed
is being monitored by the police using a radar
gun, so you can slow down.
It's obvious to see why many people think
they're illegal, since they allow you to thwart
the cop's law enforcement methods.
But surprisingly, they're not.
At least not in most countries.
They're completely legal in most of of Australia,
some areas of Canada, all of Russia, all of
the United Kingdom and all of the United States
except from Washington DC and Virginia.
However don't get radar detectors mixed up
with radar jammers, those are devices that
jam police radar signals, preventing them
from working full stop, and these are very
much illegal, using one will land you with
a $1,000 fine and one year behind bars.
On the subject of driving.
Contrary to popular belief it's completely
legal to drive barefoot.
That's right you can leave your shoes at home
and legally drive a car in most countries,
including the United Kingdom, Canada and the
US.
Although driving barefoot isn't as safe as
wearing shoes, so a lot of traffic enforcement
officers will try to tell you off for it anyway,
despite it being legal.
We all know that breaking and entering is
illegal.
So you would be forgiven if you thought that
owning and using lock picks is illegal.
But turns out, it's one hundred percent legal.
In most countries it's completely legal to
own and use lock picks, as long as you're
not using them to trespass on other people's
private property.
Most countries however, do have a law against
going equipped for theft, that means if a
police officer pulls you over at 3am and you
have a balaclava and a set of lock picks in
your car, that qualifies as going equipped
for theft and you're probably going down the
nick.
If that surprises you, how about this: In
America it's also legal to own a flamethrower.
In most countries, these fossil-fuel-burning
weapons of destruction are outright banned.
In the UK for example you will receive 5 years
in prison if you're simply caught with a flamethrower
in your possession.
But in the United States there is no federal
law against the possession and use of a flamethrower,
regardless of how powerful it is.
It's not just a deadly weapon though, in certain
states in the south of the United States and
in some south American countries.
flamethrowers are used to fend off deadly
attacks on humans from Africanised Honey Bees,
otherwise known as killer bees.
Yes you can legally own a flamethrower, but
that's not the only deadly weapon you can
legally own.
How about a tank?
Yes, in most countries you can legally own
a tank.
However don't get too excited, you can't go
all grand theft auto on innocent civilians.
The law requires the tank's cannon to be deactivated.
If you replace the steel tracks with rubber
tracks and obtain a certain permit you can
also legally drive your brand new tank on
the road.
Tanks are also surprisingly affordable.
You can pickup an ex-soviet tank for around
$40,000.
Corporal punishment in schools was outlawed
in the United Kingdom in 1987 and in Australia
in 1985.
However, to many people's surprise corporal
punishment is still completely legal in 19
states in America.
19 states including Texas, Alabama, Florida
and Kentucky still allow a teacher or principal
to punish public school students by hitting
them repeatedly.
In practice corporal punishment is becoming
increasingly less common in the United States,
however a report in 2011 showed that one Texas
school administered corporal punishment to
over 120 different kids in that year alone.
The most common form of corporal punishment
in the US is paddling, where a student is
hit multiple times on their buttocks or thighs
with a wooden paddle, however in many such
schools paddles are made from shaved down
baseball bats.
We've all seen the films and TV shows where
clever criminals count cards during casino
blackjack games to cheat the house and net
large wins, before being beat up and thrown
out by the casino's security team.
Television therefore has made it quite obvious
that card counting is illegal.
Or is it?
Well, turns out it isn't, card counting is
completely legal in the majority of countries,
including the United Kingdom and the United
States.
Card counting is a blackjack technique where
players count the cards that have already
been played to try and predict what the dealer's
next hand is likely to be.
It's widely considered as cheating and most
casinos will actively try to deter players
from counting cards by harassing players,
changing the percentage of cards in the deck
or using extremely high speed dealers.
Casinos are completely within their rights
to ban you for this, but it's certainly not
illegal.
And finally, it's not just card counting that
films and TV has led us to believe is against
the law.
As a result of it happening constantly on
TV most people believe that an undercover
police officer is required by law to identify
themselves when asked.
But it's simply not true.
A police officer is legally allowed to lie
about their status and basically anything
else they like whilst they are undercover.
They are even allowed to fabricate facts and
stories to get information.
Police do however have to identify themselves
to you if they're in uniform or taking legal
action against you.
Thanks for the view, subscribe for more Thoughty2.